okay we're gonna be swapping snacks
between Korean and American snacks are -
have you had Korean snacks I've been to
Korea but I never had Korean snacks so
you never smacked on anything in Korea I
saw a thing that they had like I thought
was just kebab then I got closing I
thought cricket sounds like now do you
know anything about Korean snacks I do
not I don't I've never had any Korean
snacks ever I had lived here for almost
20 years and I am Korean Japanese
American I am also Korean American but I
have lived in the US for a total of
maybe like ten years on and off I was
born here but then I moved to Korea and
then to Hong Kong so there's a lot of
different places so I'll be representing
Korean snacks I'll be representing
American six right here we have banana
kick believer it's next you know you
don't usually taste bananas right this
is like a staple Korean sweet snack I
don't like anything banana flavoured we
haven't dumped I also think they're
gross think about the shape it comes
from the banana enjoyed and that a kick
from the sucker when you kick the ball
it goes like this so that's why she it's
shaped like that why I was not shaped
like maybe a banana - that's a lot more
it looks like a Cheeto laughs look it's
gonna mess with my brain cuz it's not
cheese flavored
I probably last had it when I was like 8
years old I have here rice krispies
treat it's very sweet
there's like a slight chemically
aftertaste which I love
they're also styrofoam me but like the
marshmallow makes it like super super
kind of thick when I was in the military
I remember people used to sing her care
packages and on the ship we didn't have
much snacks like that it was a bit like
to see this right oh my god it smells
like banana you like banana I love
banana okay like 20 bags of these only
one gum you like it I love it
not my favorite thing to wear I don't
want another one I mean this is
definitely a nostalgic trip for me Oh
shiny look how shiny both of them are
okay this is great dense and sweet big
machines are great they just they'll rot
your teeth
it's definitely tougher to shoot em it's
good I like it I mean if you're into
sweet things this could be addicting
yeah
if I was a kid and I had this at my
disposal I'll be eating this every day
this feels like it has enough sugar to
have that whole packet so we have shrimp
crackers from the ocean also aka a um
basically means shrimp crackers I could
say this could represent Korea whether
you're young whether your kid whether
you're senior a lot of the Asian
countries have it but Korea has the best
shrimp crackers that you can find on
planet and it tastes like seafood it's
supposed to taste section it goes really
well here and I love but I am also
allergic to shrimp I do too yeah so what
I have here is pork rinds I don't know
anyone who actually eats these I
personally would have never had them my
first encounter with these was on a road
trip I've definitely seen this in some
gas station and it is like literally
fried pork skin they sprinkle some spicy
like seasoning on it I have never seen
that in my life oh man you're in for a
treat most of all I don't think I'm a
big fan of uh it smells like fat is that
how
you know okay let's let's try it don't
really persuade me to yeah but you sold
this oh yeah that's shrimpy so if you're
allergic to shellfish can I have these
I'm probably sure you can't interesting
okay
oh wow wow yeah I present taste like
cracker but then it has like a sea food
taste afterward I wouldn't necessarily
read yeah I can see this going well with
beer I'm not much about this small
already pork I love pork so I mean I'll
give it a try brave chills good chills
are bad chills imagine bacon with like
air in it feel like I'm eating styrofoam
that has a really bad aftertaste
definitely so calm these are great
I mean honestly anybody these any that
here we have this is like a stick
hovering chocolate how do you say them
Beto Beto mm-hmm it's really popular in
Korea they've actually branded so well
there's a day I remember that bit of day
November 11 it's all sticks right like
one little one you give it to the person
you like I've made hearts before I made
like books before I put letters in here
before they turn their snack into a
holiday that's what that's nuts
genius marketing genie is my genius and
then they have like a lot of flavors to
it so there's almonds cookies and cream
just chocolate covered one strawberry
banana there's a madman game when why
don't we do that way what I have here is
Twix my sister was crazy about Twiggs
chocolate and caramel covered cookie
it's kind of funny because it this kind
of has the 11 shape too
there's two in each so you kind of share
it also I have to share you don't have
to I never I've definitely tried to
explain this is Bob look at that that
this tells you well I like it thick
hahaha
yes it feels like this is something you
give somebody else yeah that you care
about whoever you want to express your
love to but I damn you I believe I don't
need no diamond ring give me pepper I
just had a flashback I asked a boy out
using Phet photo and I got rejected not
the memory I wanted to remember okay I'm
fine mmm better sweet
I haven't had twigs in over 10 years
it just got to disease homo mr.
chocolate you can't go wrong with that
there's a queer distinct point in my
mouth so it's got the extra sugar you
know ma'am it's an extra texture mm-hmm
it's it's fine it's good yeah I bet it
was good uh-huh doesn't have that mm
yeah this is like big on flavor this one
is fun again fun to eat I like these
this is just making me read you a tall
of us next we have enough like a lot of
them are just loaded with you know stuff
still great taste fantastic but it will
make your teeth hurt and this I feel
like I can do mom I look a little pepper
because I like how light it is at the
same time yep awesome yeah I think I'll
go I agree actually this is pretty good
too actually
actually I think that might have been my
favorite snack when I was a kid I
actually grew up on this when I was
younger little balls of chocolate Joey
bite into it a little surprise in there
for you I remember when you post onesies
open all the kids will be like are you I
got Teddy Grahams I already tried this
once in my life because somebody said
look like Teddy Grahams himself sounds
like they're a lunchbox staple in high
school I was really fat fatter than I am
and they used to call me a chocolate 80
gram in 2300
so everyone call me Graham all my life
so I actually have a Teddy Graham tattoo
I'll just take a bite
I don't remember hot taste I got taste
it again yeah I can see that soon oh wow
okay I feel inside it's underwhelming I
was expecting like in your face
chocolate is it this isn't a chocolate
it's it I'm gonna go with the punch oh
wow I don't know yeah okay oh is that
you eating a cookie mm-hmm and then once
you bite into it that's when the
chocolate comes out this has a stronger
chocolate flavor than that one Pop's do
whoever designed this even won't put
this song yes you're jealous
I don't like you right
oh this all day gonzo thanks oh come on
these are pretty good I still think I'm
gonna go with the total they doesn't
mean so much to me I'll take my family
all the time and it matches my hair so
yeah it does as well back in 90s when I
was a kid a lot of older generation I
know you could I've always had this you
can adjust the sugar level I guess how
so basically if you hold if you grip a
little bit uh-huh and then pour you got
you question I remember my mom drank a
lot of this I didn't because I was you
know like younger it's very convenient
you know you just open up put in your
water and for going there you shake it
up any good these are like little
grabbing those Starbucks be I still be
addicted to these it's like ice cream in
a bottle when you get a bottle like this
you need to shake it up right and New
York fizzes how we shake up our body
that's how Koreans do their soldiers
girl yeah yeah with the elbow
whoa that's really sweet yeah it's a
delicious not really delicious you can't
really go wrong with this yeah you don't
dig it before the energy you drink it
for the taste
yeah oh I like this yeah it might be
because I love vanilla it keeps like
vanilla coffee ice cool definitely takes
a little bit of coffee but not really
but it's all Pinilla and sugar can you
show me how the the sugar technology
good things are there so it's more sleep
oh that's a lot of sugar
uh-huh sugar did you pinch oh I pinched
a little bit didn't do all of it yes how
it works
oh yeah wow that was like so sugar is
that the thing we know everyone's very
great what are doing some just mixing it
all right just coffee grinds I'm just
hoping my shaking will do everything
right mr. posed to work and hot water
uh-huh but I think it will probably work
with this might be too much water now
but beyond the goal these are gonna pour
whatever water you had in New York huh
yeah you know yeah well am I here
exercising my coffee no sacred things
there shake weight yeah the shake weight
this tastes like an iced coffee this is
great for a nice treat and like I would
drink this slowly this I feel like I
would drink all day and then like all
the coffee grinds disappear it's a
little watery it is it usually this
water I mean it depends on how you like
it
mm-hmm so I mean since it comes in a
little packaging you can adjust the
water so if you like it stronger he
would take it less water or like two
packets at the same time or if they like
it like watery then don't have more
water I don't really drink Starbucks
because I know it's a lot but this what
I like about it is I just don't show you
if it's hot after you put this inside
it's sturdy that is so clever I would
definitely choose this maximum
this is a little too sweet for me yeah
whoa
perfect and that way that when I did
that to that I vomited if I'm on the
rush and stuff like that and I think I
gotta go somewhere yeah I just grabbed
this yeah pulling the bottle water and
that's it again pretty convenient I
think I like that one better
yeah you're not a very good barista I'm
not I'm jealous that you grew up with
all these delicious neg everything was
on wingman I've said this before but I
don't think there's any bad things that
I feel like overall the snacks were a
lot healthier or at least less sugary
like I feel like a lot of the things we
have in the United States are just like
home full of sugar I definitely do
prefer cream snacks everything was very
very sweet for me but I think it's very
different when you want a light snack
you can go with Korean and you could
like binge-watch something and then just
like binge eat American snacks are more
like you want sugar you want candy
here you go yeah I would not be able to
eat like a bowl of rice krispies that
would kill me but if I had like a bowl
with banana cake I could probably finish
that in like no time
[Music]